Dog the Bounty Hunter's wife Beth
Chapman has died she was 51 years old
the reality star battled cancer in the
last years of her life and was put into
a medically induced coma just days
before her death I told the doctor she
dies you die I said help me to be like
that I don't be to threaten you because
I'm a good person but doc if she dies
you die the family had been open with
fans about Beth's battle with cancer
over the last few years it's just like
hearing someone telling you that you're
gonna die you know and you're just like
what while Beth and her husband told
fans in November 2017 that her cancer
had been completely removed that cancer
picked on the wrong woman it returned in
2018
Beth underwent emergency surgery last
November to remove a mass in her throat
and began chemotherapy the next month
but was hospitalized again in April
despite her illness over the past few
months Beth was able to film episodes of
her in dogs new WGN America series dogs
most wanted
[Music]
you